we begin with the political turmoil in
Niger it's been one month since the
military detained president Muhammad
bazoom and overthrew the democratically
elected government the coup leaders have
defied growing International pressure to
release him and return the country to
civilian rule the hunter is rallying
supporters to what they describe as a
million-man March in the capital it
comes a day after hundreds of people
held a protest outside of French army
base there they want french forces to
leave in one week now the military
rulers relations with niger's former
colonial power are getting worse by the
day they've ordered the French
ambassador to leave by Sunday after he
refused to meet the foreign minister and
the West African block ecowas is
increasing pressure on the coup leaders
it says it's determined to end a spiral
of coups in the region and that military
intervention is still very much on the
table
a correspondent Ahmed Idris is joining
us live from nyame with the latest
development so the ruling Hunter has
called for a million-man margin support
of the kuak without people heating that
call
well actually the stadium behind me if I
move out of frame you see that it's
gradually filling up but it's not even
up to a quarter a quarter of what this
35 000 capacity stadium are but we
understand also that many people outside
are actually trying to come into the
venue of this uh event but it's not
clear whether they will get the 1
million people they are looking for in
fact the military tries to say that this
is a popular organization and not
induced by the military but uh it's
clear to see that most of the people
gathered here are really hardcore
supporters of the military pool in
Nigeria here earlier today there was a
smaller demonstration there was a
smaller solidarity rally uh at the in
front of the parliament from Mayors
across the country as well as Village
Chiefs and officials of very communities
across the country who met and also
declared their solidarity through the
cool Elizabeth all right now well then
is it difficult to gauge how people feel
about what's happening given the
protests against the coup soon after it
happened were very quickly broken up
[Music]
well if I get to you correctly if I get
you correctly
um the event of the past few days are
really really difficult simply because
uh right now we are seeing a diplomatic
flurry of activity the French Ambassador
here has been kicked out in the front
and France uh rejected that move saying
that the military authorities here don't
have the capacity or the authority to
send their Diplomat away now there was
confusion earlier yesterday when there
were reports in the media on social
media that several other diplomas
including those of Nigeria Germany and
the United States have been sent out of
the country given 48 hours to leave but
the Ministry of Foreign Affairs had to
intervene and debunked that rumor saying
that it's fake news but again we are uh
hearing that these exchanges between
France and Niger would escalate from The
Diplomatic level to the economic level
which could mean a serious problems for
companies uh French companies working in
Nigeria especially those in the mining
sector those have been mining uranium
for more than half a century in this
country and supplying a substantial
amount of uranium media to power nuclear
reactors in France so basically there is
that particular concern Elizabeth all
right Auckland thank you for that that
is Ahmad Idris joining us live from a
very loud stadium in the Nigerian
capital nyame thank you